I don't know how you done it all these years.
Seeing all the things ya seen and doin all the things you done.
Makes ya feel, inhuman after a while.
Captain you do know, Chief Yellow Hawk?
The army wants to be certain that the Chief gets home to Montana safely, without incident.
You have any idea, what he's done?
He's a butcher.
Then the two of you ought to get along just fine.
I've killed savages, cause that's my job.
You have no idea what war does to a man.
I hate him.
I got a warbag of reasons to hate him.
This will be done.
And it will be done by you.
Parades over.
Put em in chains.
You believe in the lord, Joseph?
Yes I do.
But he's been blind to what's going on out here for a long time.
If I did not have faith,
What would I have?
You know I've killed everything that's walked or crawled.
If you do it enough, you get used to it.
That's what I'm afraid of.
You just gotta take your dues.
We both know it could just as easily be you sitting here in these chains.
Sometimes I envy the finality of death.
The certainty.
And I have to drive those thoughts away when I'm weak.
Understand this.
When we lay our heads down out here,
we're all prisoners.